yeah we try ringing the bell I think we
should speak to these individuals one
second who are these three people hello
guys just looking for an alleged war
criminal I don't know if you guys know
this bastard yeah he's a this know yeah
who's this bastard I think he's a
bastard yeah he's a bastard he's a
bastard
31948 and we want to ask the following
questions did the boys Clubhouse carry
out the relevant due diligence and
speaker risk assessment to see if this
person Levi Simons was an appropriate
and safe person to address a group of
disillusioned young Jewish boys do you
appreciate why they're asking these
questions tou me don't try to budge me
do you appr don't tryd me asking these
I'm a m of thee war criminals yeah this
is not Israel
brother we have a brother here who we
are teaching how to pray Salah and we've
had many people learn from this math and
come to the Haram somebody prays one
Salah in the Haram it's as if they have
prayed
100,000 Salas they start praying five
times a day for fre 54 years and if you
donated for one mat and somebody played
2 days Salah it's equivalent to 1
million Salah click the button or the
link and be a part of this Amazing
Project brothers and sisters and dear
friends I woke up in the morning and I
saw a a tweet uh shared by Brother D
Hussein for another brother and I woke
up to see that and I realized that a war
criminal I should say an alleged war
criminal who has a Jew nationality has
come back from Israel serving the IDF
who are carrying genocide and apari
we've come to the building where we
think where the event happened or I'm
assuming this is where the charity is
registered who's invited to SP room now
I'm going to go to say here you okay
what's going on what brings you here in
the morning so there's a individual
called Levi Simons he's a British
Israeli Jewel National just got back
from hza yeah fighting for the IDF yeah
today he is delivering a talk as a
special guest
to disillusioned young Jewish boys why
did you say delusion disillusion why why
get that because this charity okay the
boys Clubhouse which which falls under
the umbrella of AIU UK ra to charity
claims to be helping Jewish boys who
have issues with drugs uh Vice abuse and
all these kind of things he's addressing
these group of boys today and the most
alarming thing is the following yeah
Levi Simon posted two videos on social
media which went busy while he was in
his genocidal war in hza yes video
number one was that he was rumaging
through a Palestinian woman's private
nightmare after her house was evacuated
yeah she might be dead this sister could
be dead yes but specifically when he was
rumaging through it he put it up on his
Instagram as a question and he said is
this kinky weird or Haram that means he
specifically made a reference to the
sister's religious identity he said Jal
he said J so this is the individual
that's going to be addressing young boys
the second video he filled himself
outside a decimated school which he
called a Hamas Terror school and he said
the only language that's going to be
taught in hza now or or Hebrew is going
to be taught in hza now that's a
genocidal statement why is this why is
this individual addressing young boys
yeah so let me just get this right so
this is Charity who's dealing with young
Jewish boys yes who are maybe doing
drugs or whatever for that matter and it
seems like a Good Charity in the sense
where if you're helping Jewish young
boys what I don't understand is why
would you get these kids of drugs and
get them to be war criminals or be
inspired by a war criminal this is where
I'm finding a little bit odd you want to
come and help young Jewish boys and a
question that needs to be asked is when
it comes to prevent if I we know tox tox
has gone to Syria to help is a charity
to do charity work to Aid the people who
have been going through turmoil there he
lost his citizenship he cannot come back
here if he want to come back here and do
an event and Muslim charity din
know canceled this charity what what
could the viewers do who are watching
this on your channel my channel because
this is outrageous what they can do is
they can contact the boys Clubhouse yes
they can contact the charity commission
the registered charity number is 1131
948 and we want to ask the following
questions did the boy Clubhouse carry
out the relevant due diligence and
speaker risk assessment to see if this
person Levi Simons was an appropriate
and safe person to address a group of
disillusioned young Jewish Boys number
two if they were aware what are the
justifications for allowing him and
hosting him if they weren't aware why
was there such huge negligence number
three we want to ask from the charity
commission that when you pursue and
Witch Hunt Muslim Charities for doing
far less we want you to do what we're
paying our taxes for and to investigate
why someone who has posted videos of a
decimated school with genocidal
statements rumaging through potentially
a dead woman's nightmare with religious
rhetoric why is a charity not being
investigated and looked into we want
these answers so as a Muslim charity
youve you you've wi hunted Muslim
charities for far less we want questions
answered this is what you can do so back
to it boys Clubhouse charity number I'll
go back to it again just in case 1131
948 the boys club is a trading name
underu which is a charity these are
questions you want are answered they
might think they can commit alleged war
crimes for now because we know there's
an ongoing icj case but if they come
back here thinking that they can live
without having to answer questions for
what they've done they've got another
thing coming our brothers and sisters in
Philistine I've got brothers and sisters
here they are they are resisting and
we're show solidarity with them there
those things was happening to them when
they're getting bombed they can't answer
any questions that it's winter we will
be the eyes and M and ears in this
country exactly to M Levi Sim whatever
the is called as long as we both live in
London I'm going to find you
intellectually and I'm going to confront
you intellectually just know in London
I'm going to try my best to find you and
you think you're going to get away by
going there like you said it's alleged
again he's join idea no but what he
posted was F thank you thank you let me
tell you you had fun there you're here
let me tell you something look at his
face
carefully I'm going to try to find you
and intellectually question you so again
this not a message to anybody to do
silly acts whatever I just want to come
face to face with this coward who was
going through a woman's nightwear
whatever for that matter it shows what
kind of a scumbag you are now can we
just see why are they not answer have
you tried to knock the door yeah we try
ringing the bell I think we should speak
to these individuals one second who are
these three people hello guys just
looking for an alleged war criminal I
don't know if you guys know this bastard
yeah he's a this know yeah who who's
this bastard I don't think he's a
bastard yeah he's a bastard he's a
bastard he's going through a dead
woman's nightwear are you are you part
of the boys Clubhouse yeah are you part
of the boys club boys that's where you
are you part of the boys club Simons
posted a video of himself of a decimated
School saying called it at Hamas Terror
school but said that only Hebrews going
to be taught inaz he posted a video
rumaging through a Palestinian woman's
nightmare after her home was evacuated
he's going to be addressing young boys
is that appropriate do you believe
that's appropriate tell me it's honest
question you guys do good work if you're
part of this organization you do good
work disillusion young Jewish boys is he
an appropriate individual to be
addressing young boys do you appreciate
why we're asking these questions me
don't try to Bud me do you
appdate we asking these questions I'm a
m of the Free Press you war criminals
I'm a member of the Free Press I'm
Christians yeah this is not Israel don't
ever try touching me again why are you
having an alleged trust me don't trying
me again I'm call Poli call the police
legally we are legally here criminals
why are you allowing from yes yes yes
with
us
you we just want
some your goal is to kill us your
goal is our
destruction very
one I believe these individuals may be
involved with the clubhouse the boys
Clubhouse I'm a member of the Free Press
I'm asking genuine questions we are
asking why Levi Simons is being allowed
to address young boys he posted a video
of himself he posted a video of himself
outside a school a decimated school he
he posted a video of himself rumaging
through a palestin womans dresswear
these are simple questions we
asking a coward always will belong to
us die in your age you war criminal
you're a war criminal you are a war
criminal you're war criminal
youal war criminal you guys are all war
criminals you guys are all cowards you
guys are all cowards you cowards you war
criminals you baby killers your baby
killers baby killers you baby killers
you guys are baby killers baby killers
you all cowards you're all cowards all
baby killers you're baby killers you
coward you're inviting a war criminal
you're inviting a war criminal don't
touch me don't touch me you're a war
criminal you're a war criminal you are a
war criminal that's what you are you're
a war criminal don't touch me you're war
criminal you coward war criminals war
criminals and let me get this right let
me get this right we are here talking to
them what does it say war criminals you
can see them none of them none of them
can condemn none of can condemn you're a
war criminal you're a war criminal
you're a war criminal that's what you
are you're a war criminal Levi why you
inviting a war criminal why inviting a
war criminal
Mur I'm
a I'm
Turkish
you're war criminal you cowards you card
you baby killers you baby killers you
guys are baby killers that's what you
are baby killers baby killers you are
you baby killers baby
killers shame on shame or okay so as you
can see guys this attitude is consistent
with their world view no Act of
condemnation to what Israel is doing
justification and then while we accused
of we want to kill them just for coming
here and having an honest civil
discussion this is what was coming to do
coming to ask question why are they
inviting an alleged war criminal and if
they were to they would say oh you want
to kill us who want to kill you who
wants to kill we asking for the Jews
Muslims
Christians around but when we simple
question individual as I came here to
ask you questions I've also put it in
writing now as for others turning
up F yeah so just to let you know I'm a
member of the Free Press here I came
here alone to ask questions why a
gentleman called Levi Simons who was
posting very problematic he's addressing
young Jewish boys but he's not he's not
he's not he's not here today not here
today no he's not here today okay thank
you very much that's why we're down wer
they weren't telling us that something
on the inter say he was be that's done
we're
done no no that's not that's not us
that's not on us we came here just to
ask question we came to ask questions
and it was provoked by telling us that
we want to kill him and all this kind we
ask officer we asked him
separately but as far as we're concerned
he's not here today he won't be speaking
the please please let me just read that
RG BG started when we asked questions if
they just said it's not happening we
would have gone and we're going to G
thank you thank much but please do let
them know that a because they all they
had to say wasi Simons was not here
that's it I will have a don't worry
leave that with me thank you very much
let's go
weled Madam thank you for coming
come back sister thank you for showing
your solidarity really really appreciate
the fact that you're here and I just s
today on Twitter that this war criminal
is going to be here talk I was just so
upset I only live up I live in s gate
and I've got something to go to but I
thought I need to at least go in yeah no
we really appreciate we really
appreciate the fact that no no you the
fact that you was here I mean you show
it is every day I cry I CET every day
when I see what's going on exactly and
the thing is and these people are not
listening not listening one thing that
you notice what's your name sister Ellie
sister Ellie my name is Ali yeah so one
thing that you notied is that there is
not act of condemnation when I
confronted them he's telling me Oh you
want to kill me you guys kill each other
look at your countries not a you know
what I find very bizar you know what I
yes sister you know what I find bizarre
when Isis was a couple of years ago we
as Muslims from our Layman I'm a public
figure to our imams to our leaders all
condemned Isis why because they were
carrying acts of atrocities under our
name
so so now the funny thing is this is you
look at the Layman the Zionist Layman by
the way we're not talking about Jewish
Zionist lay man to their public figures
to their Charities to the organizations
from the IDF soldiers to the ministers
to the MPS are all saying something
systematically not an act of condation
I've realized it's some kind of they
been indoctrinated because the thing is
this how could not a single Zionist come
and say to me you know what I disagree
with what Israel is doing not a s I have
not come how can they not feel bad about
this babies are dying every day how can
they not feel bad exactly they don't how
can they justify this they don't this
this is what shocks me it's a Supremacy
it's they it's a cult I realized they've
been indoctrinated I've seen the young
ones in America saying yes we've been
indoctrinated our whole
liveses our schools our you know this
charity this charity deals with Jewish
boys who've G to stet drugs Etc now you
bringing a war criminal you want to take
them off drugs and tell them all to sign
up for the IDE exactly now now it's
going to go from selling drugs at least
drugs harms you now you want to join an
army which is going to killing innocent
people unbelievable I'm humiliating the
Palestinians every day of the week yeah
but the whole world is woken up they are
losing that batt I'm telling you I'm 57
years old and I've woken up my husband's
60 we've all woken up we've realized
this has been propaganda from day one
I'm not saying that Jewish people did
not suffer more war to of course they
did but what about the rors we didn't
say let's give them part of India they
came from India let's give them part of
India and kick the Indians only that the
Jews have been living with Palestinians
and the Christians in Palestine for
centu I've spoken to Rabbi Beck yes I
know RAB spoken to Rabbi from he says
the same thing that lots of us are
saying the world is unsafe because of
the state of Israel there's more
anti-Semitism because of the state of
Israel exactly exactly and not only that
Saladin a when he conquered Jerusalem he
went in specifically we found 80
families Jewish families to come and
live with them with among the Muslims we
don't know this this anti-Semitism is
absolutely non as Muslims we have no
problem with the Jewish Community the
Christians or anyone for that matter so
Zionism is not Judaism this is because
this is this is I've educ myself thank I
want to say thank you again as Muslim
Community want to thank you we're
Christian I just think everybody should
be here I feel ashamed I can't even go
back to church now because I heard them
say yeah supporting Israel praying for
Israel and I thought I can't go back to
this church now I can't because there's
right and there's wrong there good and
there's evil and these people are trying
to say the Zionist are the children of
the light what kind of rubbish is
exactly the zionists are trying to curve
freedom of speech and everything Lally
you can't labed a anti-semite coming in
asking valid questions you know that's
why I'm going to be labeled that so
anything that you say is anti-Semitism
anything that you say which is don't
your but that's all they've got they
hav't it's not working and I even saw
the policeman taking a close look to see
if there's anything that exactly do you
see that look at the parities but sister
thank you very much it's a pleasure in
The Nut Show guys we came here this uh
alleged walking walking this this guy
that's what is for that matter see the
attitude they have consistently you see
this everywhere and anywhere
consistently these individuals do not
condemn Israel they support these people
an individual who doesn't condemn Israel
individual doesn't condemn Israel he's
outright supporting the genocide that's
happening alhamdulillah that's we're
here to do that just show their reality
from London to New York to all the way
from Israel that's all I have to say may
Allah bless you guys again brother and
sisters because of the stuff that we've
seen obviously we get passionate Etc but
yeah so please do not anyone's watching
this for that matter yes our Jewish
brothers and sisters in humanity we are
always there for them we lived in peace
for centuries and that's what we're
going to carry on doing Zionism is not
Judaism mark my words brothers and
sisters in till next
time Levi Simon look at his face
carefully I'm going to come across you
one day insh face to face intellectually
Salam